YouTube is the second most visited
website in the world and has allowed
tens of thousands of creators to make
full time income or even millions of
dollars in fact in 2017 that top paid
youtubers pulled in a combined total of
127 million dollars and this number is
just going up with individual creators
making millions themselves YouTube who
takes 40% of this revenue must be making
billions right well that's true in 2018
YouTube generated 4 billion dollars in
revenue but as much as we'd love to
complain about pre-roll ads Google
doesn't actually get the last laugh as
YouTube cost 6 point 3 5 billion dollars
to run in 2018
this means that Goa had to pay two point
three five billion dollars to simply
keep YouTube afloat that's right
Google loses money running YouTube and
this has always been the case since they
bought YouTube for 1.65 billion dollars
in 2006 ironically in 2018
you had to pay more to keep YouTube
alive than what they paid acquired
originally and things aren't getting
better either each year YouTube loses
more and more money in 2017 analysts
estimated that YouTube lost about 715
million dollars so this was a three
times increase in losses for YouTube
granted a significant portion of this
increase can be attributed to expansion
of their newer services like YouTube
gaming and YouTube TV along with their
YouTube original's initiative but a
large portion of the increase is a
result of growth on YouTube including
more videos being posted and more
traffic which both require more servers
now that you've had a chance to think
about it
you're probably like oh that makes sense
actually consider how many YouTube views
are uploaded and how many people YouTube
has to support but here are some numbers
to really put this in perspective in
2019 300 hours of footage was uploaded
every single minute now let's just
assume that the average resolution was
1080p 30 frames per second and
our of 1080p footage takes about
thirteen point five gigabytes which
means that every minute four terabytes
of footage is being uploaded to YouTube
this is the same as five thousand seven
hundred and sixty terabytes per day if
you were applying all of this to iCloud
at $10 per two terabytes you'd be
charged 28,800 to simply support all the
new uploads every day of course they
have their own service and compress
footage so they can save a lot of money
that way but this is just the beginning
what about all existing millions of
terabytes of videos on top of that
YouTube has two billion monthly users
who watched a total of 250 million hours
of YouTube per day the cost of
supporting this much streamed content is
enormous honestly I'm impressed that
they're able to get by with six point
three five billion dollars but if
YouTube is so wildly unprofitable why
does Google continue to support it the
first thought that comes to mind is that
their continued YouTube in hopes that it
will one day become profitable this
would be the same as uber or we work or
Amazon for the first 10 years or even
Amazon right now internationally but
this is actually not true in 2018 offbut
grows holding companies revenue was 136
billion dollars so four billion dollars
of revenue from YouTube isn't even 3% of
alphabet to a revenue so even if YouTube
was profitable it wouldn't be that big
of a deal for them now I'm not saying
that they won't be ecstatic if it did
become profitable but I am saying that
this isn't their focus see if you didn't
notice most cool parks actually run at a
loss from their free drive suite with
ten gigabytes of storage per account
through self-driving cars and Android
lucasz whole business model is built
upon offering unbelievably great
products for free in effort to build
rapport for the go brand and drive
traffic to go calm this is what I do
most of the data collection and
advertising and where they really make
their money all of their other products
are simply advertising for Google
via Google classroom is closed or
Chromebooks YouTube is simply an
advertising platform for
Google they're able to spend two billion
dollars to reach a quarter of the
world's population every single month
this is unbelievable value and that is
why the continued YouTube they are
willing to spend even more money on
YouTube and reach more people which is
evident in their attempts to expand so
going back to your original question how
much money as YouTube make the answer is
zero they lose money running YouTube but
they don't mind YouTube has been an
amazing advertising opportunity for them
which has created much more value for
them than the money they spend on it
every year so next time you see an ad
pop up on YouTube
take it easy on Google after all they
are paying for you to be able to watch
that video anyways if you guys would
like to see more questions like this and
surgically then make sure to subscribe
and of course leave a like if you
thought this video was informative but
until then I'm Mari I'll see you guys on
the next one